[Music]
I got
cancelled my son has cried every single
day for 3 years and it's crazy because
over the last 3 years I've cried every
single day for different reasons you
know he's like I'm hungry I'm like I
want my [__] career back
[__] doing all this therapy she said
to me well that's no surprise you're a
comedian and I said what do you mean I
know you think you like to do standup
because you like to make people laugh
when people laugh that means that they
accept you and you need that and that's
when I was like you're a [__]
[__] I'm just a guy and I'm just trying
to do better okay they don't want you to
change that's the truth I got back on
stage and people were just like what the
you but I F typed so [__]
hard
[Music]
Runk hell
hello
hello hello will
H what's really really great and
excellent is that Chris Chris was
sitting down for 15 minutes then we were
once we were ready and literally
rolling I was all settled yeah he got up
and is now not here that's really great
yeah are we going yeah okay guys welcome
to Lifeline we love you all for watching
and we love you all anyway unless you
stop watching then we don't love you it
is Sunday November five and this is
episode 82 well that's a lot of
episodes uh and you know you know what
Sundays are for Lifeline uh guys listen
uh special is available now chia.com it
is grow or die it is called grow or die
and it is available now uh go to uh
chris.com to get it it's 10 bucks and um
you know you can stream it you can
download it it's awesome dude it's
awesome it's his best special yet thank
you and he's had some really good ones
and this is his best one yet I'm really
proud of him and thank you go check it
out uh crystal.com yep and uh there's
there's a uh go sign up for Lifeline
luxury Lifeline luxury patreon.com
Lifeline luxury set it so fast uh you
know and you know what guess what I got
a new pod coming out soon a new solo pod
it's called the private record where we
have guest any old anybody who's got a
crazy story a good story a story that
you like telling a story people like to
hear come and tell it on my show tell
the whole world go check out the privat
record.com submit yourself as a guest we
want to hear from you and we want to
hear your story story uh stop flexing
Chris and uh yeah also you can reach us
at theprivate
record.com uh the private record
gmail.com on Instagram and Tik Tok at
the private record on YouTube at the
private record just find it you know the
private record okay with your host Matt
deia uh submissions send a submission
and merch Lifeline
merch.com uh you know that was such a
bad plug for the merch you know well
it's just did a lot of stuff so we
talked a lot about business so far get
the merch the merch is it is very good
it is that it is very good as mom would
say D bomb okay M would say D bomb um
and it's at lifeline merch.com and get
it all get it all get every piece oh
also you're still on tour you want to
talk about that oh yeah that's right
I'll be in Fort Meyers and Orlando and
Baltimore and Trenton and reading and
Philadelphia and uh the one Richmond
Virginia all right I got them all wow I
did it all on my on my head dude he did
it all on his head folks Oxnard
California um so yeah dude so what's up
Matt how you got how you doing man what
what is that shirt I went to
conversation school last week that's
nice and going with it went to
conversation School uh what is this
shirt dude as usual I don't know but you
tell it's old yeah I mean everything I
wear
is here's the thing about clothes you
can like up you don't need to always buy
the new ones you know
you have all of time clothing that that
clothing has been made you can buy it
from any era as long as it's still in
one piece dude it's called jerseys j e r
zes and guess what what isn't it nice it
is nice see and it's comfy and it's
jerseys okay okay but it doesn't exist
anymore probably not but if you like
this you can find it online you just
Google jerseys
okay you can't find that I bet you can't
find that one I would like a sponsorship
from jerseys so if you're listening ceoo
of jerseys hit me up did you he's dead
so did you um buy that online or at a
place uh at a place yeah at a place and
you saw it at a place and you're like oh
actually no somebody bought this for me
for for birthday they saw it at a place
uhhuh and they were seeing me later that
day they hadn't got me anything for the
my birthday and they were like that
looks like it would look good I'm at
they bought it brought it to me I was
sitting on my Throne just waiting
receiving gifts and they got down on one
knee and did this as everyone does when
they give me gift wow and like tutors
like in case I want to cut off their
head if it's a bad gift I can just do it
right then and there but this was a good
gift so I didn't cut off their head they
still have ahead you seen the
tutors went to conversation
School uh no I've not seen the tutors
but guess what I know you have because
there was a whole series of episodes
early on in the life of this show that
you wouldn't shut the fruts up about I
forgot
about watching
that cool you know what you didn't
though cuz you just brought it up I know
I just remembered again but do you know
what I am watching
currently no Luther oh I did know that
because every night at around 1:30 a.m.
you text me [__] like Luther is
engrossing exclamation point yeah Luther
is back exclamation point edrus Elba
sizzles yeah yeah so like you're some
shitty like you're Richard corus from
Time Magazine you know Leonard Malton
Leonard malton's so old only knows one
critic I know one so listen uh that is a
a show that's uh good Luther's good yeah
it's like cocaine is it like this is
Luther like this a lot yeah a lot it's
good it sounds great what's it about
Hollywood exact um it's about a it's
basically Sherlock Holmes but he's black
oh sick you know what dude one time I
just remembered this
I met Idris Elba what yeah dude it was
at the old offices of manager
company that I used to be represented by
and this was like during the wire during
while the wire was being made okay okay
and I hadn't seen a single episode of
The Wire okay I had no idea who isus Ela
was no idea what the wire I mean I knew
what the wire was okay but it was just
some show on HBO at the time while it
was on people weren't crazy about it
like they are now yeah I know you know I
know it was only after streaming was a
thing and people rediscovered it anyway
I'm walking back to my manager's
office the assistant that came to get me
I was in a waiting room with this
like straight
up the absolute most
handsome like coolest human being I've
ever been in a room with and it was I
didn't know this but it was Idis Elba
you thought that then I thought that
before anything happened right this is
the coolest guy I've ever seen in my
life and he's so [__] handsome yeah
and then uh the assistant comes on and
says have you met have you met Idris
right and I was like why the [__] would
I meet Idris they were just being like
super assistant yeah everybody's like oh
have you met some and you know like like
I would ever have a reason to uh and I
was like oh no and then we got
introduced uhuh and he was just
like he made me gay for like eight
seconds really he was just like what's
up man how you doing how old was he back
then he was young but I mean he's older
than us oh yeah he's like 50 something
so he was probably in his
mid-30s this was a long time ago yeah
yeah yeah yeah but he was the coolest
guy in the world I mean I'm sure he
still is he still looks basically
exactly the same right I know it is but
it was like I'm I'm still I'm still
amazed at how cool he was what at that
moment yeah he like in fact he was so
cool I probably would still remember who
that random guy was even if I wasn't
introduced to him and even yeah even if
I didn't put it together I never met him
well I'm cooler I want to meet him you
know it's crazy
because uh he it's crazy that he's a
human and also like you know another
short fat guy as a human so high right
now way you're talking uh sucks yeah it
sucks for the short fat guy yeah like
for guys like me and El elra it's like
cool and then for guys like you and
[__] you know Danny DeVito yeah it's
like all right yeah I hope you're funny
yeah you know but me I got the whole
package so it's like nah nobody's got
his package dud no you think he's got
the most amazing well yeah I mean maybe
he's super something else that you don't
know though boring of course who knows
I'm just saying the way he presents is
like the
most he is a DJ magnificent what he is a
DJ he's a DJ he does DJ sets wow yeah
which is why does every actor want to be
a DJ too you know why cuz they're both
[__] easy as [__] jobs acting is way
harder than being a DJ except for not
well except for when you you know the
lifestyle it's hard to be a DJ cuz you
going to [__] be up till 6:00 a.m.
the truth is acting is hard unless you
have the knack for it and then it's easy
like watch
this that's really bad but oh I mean in
like a comedy that would have been bad
but in a real searing true to life drama
people would have been just balling in
their seats if that was a movie I'll
show you good acting okay don't don't it
doesn't end till it don't I'll decide
when it end say it ends so I know so
don't be like oh that before it ends um
oh I'm sorry ma'am I must have wasted
both of our times uh my mistake I'll be
on my
way there is one
thing that's been on my mind okay I'm
done I that was pretty good yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the longer the pause
the better acting is that right I'm
sorry ma'am uh I must have wasted both
of our times uh you're in the clear I'll
let my I'll let myself
out there
is one thing I'd like to ask you about
speaking a waste of time that was pretty
impressive an impressive waste of time
it's good acting bro yeah check this out
though
okay that's bad no it's like if you're
really like in a life or death situation
and Sling Blade
[Laughter]
and dude Sling Blade uh all right so my
acting was good mine was epic okay epic
I just think that uh why do they every
detective show do that the thing you did
yeah uh I don't know cuz it's like
suspenseful easy cheap suspense if
you're a detective and you go in you go
in with all the information you don't
leave and then go oh yeah something else
well that's the joke about Columbo you
know one more thing you know literally
turned into like a cultural joke that
everybody understood yeah columbos if
you watch I love Columbo so I'm about to
talk [__] about it but know that I love
it okay the formula of Columbo is is
this the first 20 minutes of every
single episode Peter [__] is not even in
for one second what it follows the
criminal doing the thing what entirely
so you know all of the facts of
everything what and then Columbo shows
up 20 to 30 minutes in what and it's so
bad from that point on it's so good
until Columbo shows up every single
episode because you just know he's going
to solve the casee and he's always going
to at the end of every scene it's going
to be like oh he didn't figure out
anything the criminal is going to get
away and then it's one more thing wow
and he actually says one more thing in
almost every instance in that show so
it's like his trademark so you why do
you like it
then because the first parts are always
so good like the acting is amazing the
writing is amazing they come up with new
like reasons for crimes new ways people
messed up covering them up it's smart
cool oh really but then he shows up it
was on in the 80s so dumb uh I think it
might have been' 70s late 70s yeah oh
then it was rerun when it was the ' 80s
well no no no actually okay so the first
few seasons were like 8 to 10 episodes
mhm uh and then it got really popular
then there were like so it was streaming
but then like late Seasons it went into
the 90s but they would make them movies
it would be Columbo movie God all right
right so it would be like only four of
them a year but it would be like a TV
movie Columbo yeah Jesus okay well
anyway who cares I guess right gonna no
I know it the the listeners of Lifeline
definitely don't care about I guarantee
you a lot of these people have watched
Columbo it's weirdly the Resurgence is
so weird the Resurgence of Columbo dude
yeah it's a very weird thing people are
like yeah I watch Columbo and you're
like oh it's old how do you have there's
so many new
shows that people who care about being
in like the cultural conversation have
to watch how do you also have time to go
back and watch Columbo I only watch
Columbo I'm not doing any of stuff it's
it's on like I know it was on Netflix I
know it's on tuby now it's on everything
I think tuby has the craziest [__] Tu is
the best dude don't [__] with me tub's
where it's at I know because has
everything yeah you can find truly
obscure weird there's home videos on
basically there's Home Videos yeah which
I would I love that you're like darius's
birthday party right yeah darius's 11th
birthday party uhhuh from like 1981 yeah
and you're just like oh happy birthday
dear Kleenex and there
commercial and it comes back
darus yeah that's that's to be all right
let's get into it uh let's get into
it
uh look at it taking a [__] face dude
taking a [__] me also me but taking a
[__] no ringing the doorbell in The
Purge
oh dude GNA kill your whole family we
love this guy this guy was wait hold on
hold on don't ruin it was is wearing the
same shirt as last time yeah and just
hasn't slept no doubt he's recreating
the magic this is the dude who let the
[__] the greatest sub juts out the
the had the greatest submission with
this with the toothbrush and he had to
move it for his his girlfriend's
toothbrush he has an issue with his
girlfriend she leaves the toothbrush on
the edge of the sink go back if you're
watching this Lifeline just and you
haven't seen the last one go back watch
the last video in the last episode this
guy moralized us yeah he made us laugh
very hard and we love him and now I
guess he's back I hope he has a new one
but let's see yeah from the beginning
start it over make it go from the
beginning do not start it when you did
which was before we said start it start
it and when we say start it and started
which is
now what's up Chris and Matt this is
Anthony from Phoenix with the girlfriend
that uh just can't seem to put her
toothbrush in the right spot oh I laid
out the crime scene for
you here we are at my pants imagine with
me I'm done brushing my teeth I have a
mouthful of toothpaste I need to spit
the toothpaste out and rinse out my
mouth so I go to reach down oh my
eyeball hits right on the wet bristles
right there now could I go down on that
side yeah but I'm right-handed it feels
awkward to go down on that side plus I'm
eye to eye with this toothbrush here
which just pisses me off even more so
every time I need to pick it up put it
over here and then go about my day now I
didn't get upset about this the first
several times this happened of course
it's innocuous it's silly but after the
fourth or fifth time or
so what a down to it
wow it's the same amount of effort to do
this yeah yeah okay then it is to do
this right understand yeah so it's a net
loss for all of us I mean American psych
you agree for all of us I mean and Chris
hell yeah when you're back in Phoenix me
and my girl are going to get some VIP
tickets and we'll get to meet you I'll
even buy a coffee if you're free oh wow
wow dud this guy her dead body is on the
premises while he's
taking her dead body is probably in the
shot in the bathroom mirror somewhere go
back it goes internet go back and find
it
yeah the DAT line so um hold
on H this is just here's the deal the
bottom line the bottom line of all of
this is dude the act out of when he hit
it dude that was great but it's
not it's and look at it that was good
it's not a big enough deal to get upset
about it I get obviously I've been in
relationships where the my partner does
like a certain weird specific thing that
is like hard to whatever run into over
and over and over again but even this
this is it doesn't even reach that
threshold to me I don't
know sure but the other things you have
a problem with somebody else might not
but right that's kind of what I'm trying
to say yeah there there the I there is a
reason though I think she's doing that
mhm and she has a reason so that to me
makes it a little bit okay do you know
what the reason is I know what it is
yeah she doesn't want the water to drip
down into the thing and get moldy
correct which is ultimately a noble
cause it is it is it is that it is a
noble cause but there is a way to defeat
eat all
that okay go ahead solve the problem for
them I can help both of you great get
the get a piece of to of um Kleenex or
toilet paper put it at the bottom of
that thing and then the water just fills
up that but then you got to always
dispose of that thing you actually have
to do it way less than you think here's
what is the other way to do it if you're
her just go do the Bob Ross thing dude
just bang the heck out of it is that
what he says just bang the heck out of
it when he cleans the brush
just that's what the porcelain on the
sink is for to get banged against by
your toothbrush okay just bang the heck
out of it just bang the Daylights out of
it just bang the diggity dog out of it
okay just bang the bing bong out of it
just bing bing bing bing and then put it
away everyone's happy look at his face
right there yeah he should host a
children's show do yeah he should and
it's very obvious to everyone who's ever
met him so hold on play it again we have
to watch it
again serial killer what's up Chris and
Matt this is Anthony from Phoenix with
the girlfriend that uh just can't seem
to put her toothbrush in the right spot
wow I laid out the crime scene for you
crime scene this part it is kills here
we are at my sink imagine with me I'm
done brushing my teeth I have a mouthful
of toothpaste Christian I to spit the
toothpaste out and rinse out my mouth so
I go to reach down oh
my
eyeball why are you hits right on the
wet bristles right there now could I go
down on that side yeah but I'm
right-handed it feels awkward to go down
on that side plus I'm eye to eye with
this go over it toothbrush here which
just pisses me off even more so every
time I need to pick it up put it over
here and then go about my day good now I
didn't get upset about this the first
several times this happened of course
it's innocuous it's silly but after the
fourth or fifth time or
so whates down he you know what happened
there for her what it's he got amount
boiled up the fury boiled up and he got
overheated and he forgot what was to do
this so it's a net loss for all of us
wow don't you agree it's convincing
argument cut and Chris hell yeah when
you're back in Phoenix me and my girl
are going to get some VIP tickets and
we'll get to meet you dude that me and
my girl who if she's still alive we will
come to see you in
Phoenix I got I I cannot wait to meet
this girl a great guy what if she shows
up and she's just crying and she's just
like I don't understand the problem I'm
sorry no she slips you a note says
please help me like she's he only let
her out one time to see you at your show
you know yeah yeah yeah she's got like
uh ligature marks yeah on her wrists
well thanks for the update bro uh we
love it we you provided a lot of
entertainment for
us uh um we love you oh God and your
girlfriend who we hope is still alive
but we're not quite sure they obviously
have a really good relationship if she's
allowing him to do this J you know yeah
they obviously have fun with it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah well I mean I hope
so unless she has no idea that it's even
happening she she doesn't even know who
you know what Lifeline is or who we are
he's just dragging her in out in the
world and she has no clue yeah all right
dude well we love you thanks again yeah
who's next let's do next
one hey guys um I'm Teresa from
Pennsylvania um I have an advice
question I train Jiu-Jitsu pretty
regularly it's a huge part of my life
but it's not like my whole personality
it's not like it's on display at all
times um but whenever anyone finds out
that I train Jitsu whether I tell them
or we're just like getting to know each
other talking about things that we like
to do with our
time the reaction I get is like almost
always so you could beat me up oh of
course how
the [__] do you respond to
that I always want to just sigh and
go wish you didn't do that I wish you
didn't do that but that just like ends
the interaction and I'm strange and
awkward as it is so I don't know if I
want to like amplify that I don't know
don't know how to respond I figured
maybe you guys
would I know what to do kick their
[__] ass no no that's a lot you just
go
could have killed you dude
that's that's yeah well because okay
she's I think she's talking about guys
probably that is what I I don't think
women would probably say she didn't
specify no but she went uh uh and that's
the dude kind of voice um I think that
uh it's
not just I would just say every time I
say this to a dude that they they say
that and and also if you're mad enough
no you know people seem to think that
like you know Jiu-Jitsu is very
technical and very good but like you
know there's no way that if a big guy
fought her that he would lose it doesn't
matter how much he
knows is I'm not doubting that but I
that sounds not right to me yeah if the
guy's big enough and angry enough no way
why like just cuz of she gets too close
up to her like she's [__] you mean the
the the strength is completely different
but I imagine him if he's untrained in
any martial arts right he would maybe
try to hit her and she would get out of
the way and then disable him somehow I
don't know what I'm talking about that
is evident but like it's not I mean it
could happen but no she could she could
beat up women it's just a completely
different thing huh yeah and I'm not
saying like
look take a cage fighter different but
I'm talking about like she's not a cage
fighter you know right yeah somebody
that just trains in Jiu-Jitsu no way
right yeah I I bet you my
ass I bet you really yeah well I don't
know how big she is but you know yeah I
mean I'm completely untrained in
everything
besides but you're 6'2 martial art
kicking your ass whoever you are oh okay
that's what I excel in yeah I would just
goth can attest to that um yeah I would
just say
okay everybody says this so congrats
you're not original thanks very much and
then when they do that do a thumb lock
on them nice to meet you and that's good
but I also like could have killed you
could have killed you you know I also
like uh really like rubbing their nose
and how typical they are yeah so maybe
you could be like oh you know every
single person says that when I mention
that it's so annoying why do you guys
all do that this is really good too kill
them kill them like that yeah get make a
100 cards that's have in quotes just
does that mean you can beat me up we
went up you had this in mind for someone
else yeah I did and and then when they
say that just hand them one of those
cards they would feel like such a
[__] [__] that's so good that's so
good somebody gave me cards at a show
probably the last one I did maybe maybe
Cleveland something but um at the meet
and greet she goes here I have these and
I think that you could use these and
there she gave me cards there's probably
50 of them in there they're like
business cards and they um and they say
they say please stop talking and I give
them to people if they talk too much oh
that's just rude though yeah it's great
oh okay it's great give them to my wife
give them to my friends give them to oh
you're a dick okay yeah well my wife is
like you didn't clean up the dishes I
go she just hands you one back says
please do the dishes yeah yeah yeah
she's got 50 cards to say please do the
dishes all right cool well yeah your
dude remember that business card thing
also maybe dude
I mean unfortunately sometimes it just
comes down to maybe just don't say it to
certain people only tell people that you
do Jitsu that you're interested in
having a real conversation with other
seems like she doesn't it's not her she
say it's not her whole personality
though she probably does do that I'm
saying to protect yourself from that
maybe be even more guarded with who you
tell cuz that sounds so annoying that is
so annoying if you can help yourself
maybe do it that way too yeah that's the
whole I'm a comedian I'll tell me a joke
thing yeah yeah mean it's deeper but
remember the no and it's cool cuz we you
know we work through it but like um do
you remember the business card thing
play the business card cuz of the stock
thing Mako it's cuz of the stock dude
what is it called your business card is
trash it's going to come up right away
just put crap your business card is crap
funny bu funny business card guy I bet
comes up right away is
crap this guy oh dude this guy's a
legend but not enough of business
card don't let that be your
apprehension
don't let not having the tools be your
trepidation these are the gift the prize
you don't spend the money until you've
made the money and then you only spend a
percentage of it and you buy the best
quality you can buy you see that
business card cheap Strathmore stock 60
PB holds a crease can you tear it
absolutely the best looks like crap it
is crap it's the same size of every
other business card in my hand that you
guys just gave me these aren't even your
cards that card looks like crap too one
color nothing special about it let me
see what's it say on it name of the
company in Atlanta it's an
agency this guy's
a CSO Chief strategic officer wow I'm
impressed so what he's an officer I know
companies that are worth $10,000 a year
and the guy's a CEO I will never make a
criticism if I don't have resolution yo
pause it you see that car I love dud
look at what he presents it's the
shittiest if anybody that I might be end
up in business with that I was like a a
prospective possible business person
that I could go into business with if
card like this I would never ever get
into business dude where do you put it
exactly it's a CD you need to have a
purse if you keep playing
play this is this is the most impressive
business card I've ever seen it's
mine it took me 25 years to design this
that this card is expensive about $4 a
card oh my God because of the stock it
doesn't fit in a roll index because it
doesn't belong in a roll ofex it's the
kind of thing where your card should be
so good that even if they don't like you
they won't throw it out yes it
demonstrates incredible marketing
capability I mean opens
life is not about like aing being
effective my card is diecut oh my card
is foil stamp my card is embossed look
at the way the shoulder guarante you're
kidding my card instead of telling you
that I'm a CEO cuz who cares about my
title tells you about the result I
generate I build
crows
guaranteed what do you do guaranteed I
love this guy God say own I I I build
crowds who is that guy what does that
mean what do you do guarante just
creates Havoc riots dude I build crowds
dude who is that guy how much did he die
of HIV I once did a deep dive and he
there's another video of him out on
online talking about the popularity of
that really yeah I don't like when they
do that I want the guy live as that
forever I don't want them to be like
yeah it was a silly thing you know I no
he's not doing that oh good no he's like
he's like that's what I do he's not like
walking it back still doing it yeah it's
not like him being like I know that was
funny but good good good good good he's
exactly like that still oh God it's
because of the Stu well I mean taking it
so to the next level didn't because of
the Stu wasn't like that will
farell dude that is so funny it's so
funny that I've exhausted how many times
I've laughed at that what's so
unbelievable he keeps opening up dude at
the end he's just the part where his
should like his shoulder comes to a
point at the end of the card it's like
so it's going to injure you oh yeah if
you try to put that in your pocket
you're going to get poked it's going to
hurt and you're going to rip it up or
burn it out of Spike I mean dude he says
dude he says even if you hate
me uh you won't get rid of it you still
won't get rid of it yeah could you
imagine getting that and the next thing
you you don't do is just toss it in the
trash immediately immediately guess what
guess what I wouldn't do that with
though a regular business card I know
you just go what he's saying is
completely the opposite of the truth was
he the first delusional guy like on
social media no but okay he's working
he's really carrying the torch for
delusion this is this guy worth a if
he's worth a billion dollars okay but
he's not of course not how could he be
it's so even talking about when have you
ever gotten a business card that you can
open like it's a a popup book for kids
he has another business card that he
uses for a bookmark in his own business
card you open up the business card and
like a tiger pops out you know and an
elephant goes like this like my son
would look at that business card for
[__] 25 minutes yeah exactly and then
you get hurt with it cuz it's got a
pokey Edge he'd stab Billy with it
anyway we got we got to keep going with
this another one all
right what's up Chris and Matt I got a
question for you the head of security
nobody gets past the Tall Grass I got
the life rips mouth guard right here and
uh man it's kind of old so I got a
question for you what color scheme
should I get to use for my fight
December 16th UFC 296 at the T-Mobile
arena in Las Vegas let me know I'm
getting a new one baby life awesome dude
head of security for the Log Cabin uh
our favorite UFC fighter he's killing it
actually he's doing really well um and
we support him 100% love this dude dude
I I just real quick I saw him completely
not through you after a fight that he
won and he was smiling and he was
showing the mouth guard life rips and I
was like what the [__] does it say my
brother's thing in his mouth yeah that's
funny and then and then I it is that and
then I realized what why didn't you tell
me bad brother huh because you already
knew how did you know I knew because
then I reverse engineered got it I got
it we love this dude killer yeah I okay
so well what color scheme I don't know
man I mean look I know fighting is manly
and [__] like that but I go bright
especially if it's in the little thing
right there in the you know got Pop I
would go bright neon green or like a one
of those glow-in-the dark colors ooh
this is what I vote for but that might
be kind of you got to also think about
it's in your mouth though so it could be
kind of like you don't want to be green
cuz that might be gross uh like a hot
pink want but you need to be but it
needs to be light enough to where you
see the dark letters though right so it
see the dark letters so this might be
too dark lighter than this a green a
green that's lighter than this yeah yes
dude that was so quick if you want more
than one color though that and hot pink
would be sick yeah but you won't be able
to see it why won't you able to see it
hot pink is the most visible color but
that and hot pink what what color the
letters maybe you don't want pink or red
in your mouth though too saying you
didn't say that don't act meant that I
meant that I meant that but what about
oh ooh what about no no the light green
the light neon kind of hen say color
scheme it makes you think you want one
color and then another compl yeah I
think that he meant I mean it's such a
small area you got to pick one color and
then you got to make the give him
another color in case he needs another
one all right but it's like all right um
about the light green two-tone green no
because then you can't see the letters
oh yeah the letters have to then the
letters only have to be black right so
it has to be right right right the the
other the other color is black it has to
be light green like this shade but
lighter and then black there you go how
do you make one of those by the way he
he handm makes
it he hand makes his own
mouth when he's not training it's his
second toal yeah like this he does it
when he's on the
elliptical he's the man dude we love him
he's my favorite UFC fighter cool yeah
the guy's good that's cool it's good
it's cool I love it ah it's good and and
and that and that Vibe the life rips
that's how he's winning dude that's how
he's winning even if you lose life still
rips you got to remember that's when it
ripped but he's not going to lose cuz
he's the man yeah he's not going to lose
all right cool he's cool God bless him
and his wife I'm
religious Caprio oh my God in The
Departed dude leard Caprio in The
Departed go back RND dude Leonard
DiCaprio in The Departed he's just going
to start begging us for like Med like
pills he can take to to numb his mind
all right cuz he goes through so much
[__]
what do I do about my forehead oh I have
a pretty large forehead and Everywhere I
Go people comment on it um talk about it
you know anytime I don't wear a hat that
is um and you know most times lately
especially I have been wearing hats um
so you know to cover it up um so what do
I do about my forehead I'm thinking uh
do I just go bald um you know my dad's
bald a lot of my family MERS are bald um
you know but then I think well I don't
really have the muscles to be going bald
um so should I be hitting the gym and
then going bald um you don't just for
reference this is what my hair looks
like I mean bro who's making fun of you
what kind of [__] are you
surrounding yourself you have a regular
ass forehead yeah I mean that's not even
a five head you're going bald well
you're going bald exactly but it's
forehead's a normal [__] size yeah no
one has hair in their forehead that's
his head they're getting in your big
head they're getting into your
regularized head regular sized regular
foreheaded head dude I think uh I think
that if you that this brings up a great
point though that I have said if you're
bald you got to have a good
body you cannot be bald and fat and you
can't be bald and too skinny or just
have a flabby nothing body if you lose
your
hair the acceptable thing to do to be in
society is have a great
body I don't like what you're saying I
don't like it either I I wish it wasn't
true I don't like it either what about
the guy in Night Court who just died he
was bald okay and his body was whatever
he was the man but he's probably really
tall right yeah he is really tall fair
enough he's big enough oh so you can be
really tall and not have a great body
he's not fat though he's like just got
big dense body Okay so if you have big
dense body and you're bald that's okay
okay but if you are bald and you do not
have big dense fat big dense body and
you're fat or just flabby
skinny if you're bald not good enough oh
also he's not bald look he shaves
it that's hilarious oh oh wow I didn't
know that me neither yeah rip though
Richard Maul dude you were the men you
were so funny in Night Court wonder why
I was bald in Night Court just like
getting into the character man you know
he's not bald wow see there you go it
one for me yeah he actually got a great
head of hair yeah he's got great hair
hair like Dad look at that yeah you
don't think about that click on the one
all the way to the right result yeah
naturally that one
yeah yeah I mean he's literally got a
great head of hair I mean that is Dad
that
guy that's so interesting that he shaved
it cuz everyone knows him as a shaved
head guy yeah that's actually so good
for him imagine being super
recognizable bald but actually having
hair that's like such a good
life ah you know what I'm saying like no
one would stop him on the street he's so
recognizable though I bet you I feel
like I feel like he's too I would I
would you I would would not I would I be
like that's the guy that's my favorite
actor Richard Maul uh he just died huh
he just died yeah really like this week
mhm oh really like by the time of this
recording it'll have been over a week
but yeah oh wow so um that's too bad he
was he was 80 huh he looks he looked
great that makes well we don't know when
that was taken right right but I me but
if that's him in his 70s he looked great
yeah that's great
um some people just die huh everyone
actually not just no but some people
it's just
like like and they're 80 and it's like
some people they decline I guess most I
don't know most people well I mean to
some degree and I guess we haven't se
like you know we don't know what his
last year of life was like he's 80 he
could have been anything I know but but
some people you're just like like you
you see them and they're like wow he's
great and then they die correct yeah
that's [__] up I wish you're just
realizing this you're 43 years old no I
know but it's like I want it to I want
people to I want people to
know I I wish we
knew I don't wish we knew when it was
coming from birth I wish we got like
okay you got you know
two years left God I'm so happy we don't
we don't have that that would ruin the
world me too if everyone knew me too
from 2 years out when they were going to
die me too it the world would have
already been destroyed first of all I
know but it it would not work it become
completely I don't wish that it would be
good for everyone else in your life to
know but not you if you had like a force
field around possibly knowing and people
who love you got to know you'd be tell
that would be fine you'd be able to tell
people would be treating you way saying
if you had a force fi around possibly
knowing like no you couldn't get the hey
Jim's here I'm talking about like an
actual thing not I hope you're really
enjoy this birthday party so annoying
not that everyone has to keep it a
secret you [__] happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear Jim one of the
most important people I ever met in my
entire life just I hope he knows
that it's weird that we want people
before they die to know how much they
mean to us it's like uhhuh they're just
going to die just do that before then do
that your whole life because that's when
it matters don't cram it in at the end
it's like
it's God I mean we have to say it right
I could just start laughing my brother
just farted in the middle of me making
an important point about life even my
butthole has good timing
wow on your uh gravestone even his
butthole here lies a man even whose
butthole had good
timing uh yeah I completely forgot I was
going to say but a fart will do that to
you yeah a fart will do that to you okay
I ate a uh
nope that's not what we do we don't go
into the details of what we ate after we
fart people don't want to know the
specks of a fart you know what's what
specs got on that like it's a car yeah
EX
oh hey what kind of what kind of f was
that yeah nobody wants that dude was
Ling eight and then the meal before that
too cuz could no I I had a a [__]
congrats we don't care what's uh oh hold
on man all right all right all right I
want to talk about it separately it has
nothing to do with the fart well now it
does it's inextricably T everybody farts
all right everybody fart inextricably
tied to the fart everybody farts
everybody
toot so hold on last night last
night I ain't a [__] poptart you did
no oh okay well what I did don't mislead
us tell us what tell us the truth you
did poptart what kind no I didn't need a
poptart this
sucks which is it
dude you're like you're talking to the
Riddler talking to the Riddler what is
the truth retired Riddler but still has
the life in him and can't stop imagine
the rther on a first date she's like
what the [__] I don't know what believe
you or is
[Music]
it she's just like [__] he was nice but
like I couldn't tell what was true
that's right I've got the beef sirloin
for you and what about you boy I would
like something that lives at night but
night's so so um uh last night
mhm I I
got a burger mhm Will William shner I
couldn't remember what I got and then I
got it from Fred 62 you know that place
I do okay they have their own Pop-Tarts
that they make oh yeah so it's not a
poptart it's whatever it is they right
yeah so I got it yeah and I ate that and
I don't think it was that good it wasn't
good it was
fine what a tale you know nobody tells
them like you do I don't think that I
don't think that they should have it on
their menu yeah I know what you mean no
because it's it's fine yeah Fred 62 is
not a great place it's really
not go oh dude I'm wrong no oh you're
right it's fine no I'm not [__] on
it it's borderline fine less than fine
it's like a diner just any diner yeah
it's no swingers swingers is great for a
diner swingers is better for sure the
101 was the best but yeah it's gone now
now it's a different place I can't
believe it's gone it's a different place
now I know I think the menu is roughly
the same though oh I think I'm not sure
I have no idea you're talking out of
your ass okay so I haven't been there
since but
um what was I going to say no one knows
something about the Fred 62 oh yeah dude
I go on Postmates you know to get them
to freaking bring it you know the burger
MH the burger is
$25 you know it's crazy man things cost
so much now dude a burger is $25
you know what's the sad truth is
probably they probably can't even stay
in business if they make like that's
it's not even they're like let's [__]
people over they're like the meets this
buns that the [__] you know what I mean
it's like [__] so expensive now across
the board D and it showed up and it was
not a $25 Burger of course not like you
go to a place to a restaurant you get a
burger honestly if you go to a nice
restaurant and get a $25 Burger that's
expensive totally yeah this [__]
Burger was 251 it was actually 251 okay
well that Penny doesn't matter at all
but yeah that's what it was and it was
so mid bro it wasn't bad though it was
just whatever it was fine right okay it
was it was truly fine but dude David's
was even worse cuz his second Pat was
super small know why I know why guess he
probably ordered something shitty with a
bunch of [__] on it that's so he got no
cheese on it and uh dude and whatever it
was bad but anyway how about when people
act like they're eating healthy and they
order something that's just a [__]
mess for your body but you get it with
like no cheese you get it get something
shitty for your body but no no bun God
forbid that's legit I I did I said that
on stage a few nights ago because of
David Sullivan yeah that's the most
David Sullivan thing D he will be like
man dude this dude I this is what I was
talking about on stage basically the bit
but part of it but I was like uh cuz you
have that one friend that is just like
oh man I think it's that cheese like I
think I got cheese you know and it's
like dude you ate a [__] chair you
know what I mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah dude it's so it's so ridiculous
[__] he eats us I used to live with a
guy when then they'll be like well it
had dairy in it right yeah I lived when
I lived in New York uh I lived in this
shitty old tenement style railroad style
uh a forf flight walk up you couldn't
even get to the main area without going
through other people's bedrooms that's
railroad style right yeah that's
terrible that terrible and uh one of the
dudes used to order from this thae place
all the time and before the food would
get there he would run downstairs to the
little Bodega on the corner of the
street and get a cup of coffee okay to
have with his Tha food oh God no and I
was always like listen there's going to
come a day that you're going to be so
[__] up that you're going to do what
you're doing now MH and you're going to
need to go to the emergency room and
guess what I'm not going to help you do
that I'm not going to be the one that
goes with you because I'm telling you
now it's going to happen and it's going
to be only your own fault okay okay I
swear on my [__] life okay like
either a month 3 months I don't know how
long the distance was he that happened
he got such terrible food poisoning that
he had to go to the [__] hospital and
then what he was there for a whole
[__] day did you go with him no my
other roommate did cuz I was like I'm
not going I told you we all knew it was
gonna happen I'm not wasting a [__]
day at a hospital because you sent
yourself there but but but he could have
just disagreed that it was going to
happen he could have what did he
disagree it was gonna happen yeah he was
like what it's fine he's like I never
get sick from this I was like okay
you're gonna and when that day comes I'm
not helping you why did you think it was
going to happen have you ever eaten Thai
food yeah a few times and have you ever
Dr had coffee in your life yes that's
why okay but that doesn't mean you're
going to get food poisoning it just me
you're going to [__] up it's like
throwing matches
near tanks of gasoline with big wide
openings that the match could fall into
and then someone being like well doing
that might actually blow something up
you think so yeah I was right though so
I don't think so I know so was it food
poisoning no no I mean I don't know I
guess I don't know the clinical term for
whatever why did he go to the hospital
bro because he was he was like uh Jeff
Daniels and Dumb and Dumber you
know feet off feet off the ground like
that yeah exactly dude you know when
you're there and you're sitting there
and you're like oh and you know what I
mean I let it go be honest happen to me
in so long I know but I I do it it could
something nice about
just something nice about it it's so
gross dude but it is though it is that
dude I I when last time you had food
poisoning where was coming out uh oh
dude oh my God I had such bad food
poisoning remember that at the beach
that one year no oh I was vomiting so
hard I was never so I don't I don't even
think about it [__] so
hard at the beach what beach what like
what Seal Beach when oh man I mean it
was a long time ago oh wait yeah I do
remember that this during my first
marriage yeah you were acting like a
[__] on the couch the whole time bro I
was in the bathroom the whole
time D it would come out and you be it
was the kind where it would just be like
like where you're just it's just firing
out you can't and dude and the best part
was like you know I don't know if Dad
came in once and was just like you're
right and then they're just go they I I
just I know they're in bed just like
this yeah and I'm
just it's 3:00 a.m. dude and they're
just and everyone else is
just I
couldn't stop dude and it did not come
out of my butt it did not come out of my
butt yeah well that's even worse because
then it's just disgusting when it when
it comes out of both when you're
vomiting and it's coming out of your
Bump at the same time yeah dude I know
somebody that that's happened
simultaneously yes and they they were
like you have to choose one it was like
I got to throw up and [__] which one
hits the B chose wisely wow that sounds
like the worst and they were they were
vomiting in the thing and [__] out
on the floor yeah dude don't make that
choice I don't
know don't make but grab a trash can
[__] in the toilet and throw up can we
just do you know what I mean you don't
always have the whole here's here's the
thing though you don't you you can't
just you're in different positions cuz
you're contorting and you got to fall
down you got to get up you got so you
know you're hanging you're like oh no
and you throw up and uh oh and it comes
out too like you're just the bathroom's
just a war zone God it's interesting how
I think I've had food poisoning once it
does I get sick a lot in a lot of
different ways my stomach is like a
[__] made of iron I've had it either
one that one time or or maybe another
time oh you too you know yeah I wonder
that about very rarely
even I remember there was there was one
time I realized I hadn't thrown up in
like over a decade yeah yeah cool I'm
great all right let's do one more before
we're done all right all
right hi Chris and Matt Sam from Toronto
I was hanging out with some buddies
recently and uh as you as you are when
you get a bunch of dudes together um
it's the randomst most random stuff
comes up um somehow the topic of
conversation going ways in which you put
your pants on making it up
and seemed like the
consensus was that most people most of
the guys I was talking to at least both
the the so that the pants are on the
ground and way describing both feet go
in and they pull straight up from there
and that was ludicrous to me I could not
believe that it was pretty much
everybody there thought that was the
best way I have always I had to think
about it cuz I like so such a random
thing but I do a one step in then
halfway up and then the other light goes
in
all the way up um am I crazy is that not
what people normally
do World in you would put hang out with
a bunch of three or foury olds and then
pull up from there like what the [__] do
I need to rethink my life um dude that's
like anyways help me out here guys um
yeah that's like people that's like
people who what that's like honestly
people who go to the bathroom in the
urinal and put their pants all the way
down to the angles dude like what are
you doing Matt McMurray if you're out
there watching I was friends with you
when we were like five or six uh you
lied and said you had seen Total Recall
when you in fact hadn't seen Total
Recall anyway this isn't about that we
just non SEC one time you were at my
house hanging out with me and Steven Leo
and for some reason we're all being
rough and just being like you know
little Knuckleheads cuz that's what five
and sixy olds are but Matt went Matt you
went to the bathroom this a confessional
I'm speaking directly to you Matt you
went to the bathroom and I thought it'
be funny to barge in on you uh but you
were peeing standing up and your pants
were all the way down to your ankles and
I felt so embarrassed that for you that
I tried to quietly close the door so
that like you wouldn't know I barged in
but as I'm coming back out Matt like you
like turned your head to like look over
and when you did that I shut it real
quick and Matt was like what were you
doing why were you coming to the
bathroom and I was like I didn't do it I
didn't do it I didn't I didn't that
didn't Happ it didn't have let me tell
you it did happen that's the stupid bad
because you were acting like a little
kid even though you were a little kid
nobody want no little kid wants to be
acting like a little kid you know what I
mean it's embarrassing and I was
embarrassed for you and I still don't
know why to this day your pants were run
your ankles when you were only peeing
but how old was he five or
six no uh I guess yeah maybe maybe seven
I don't know I mean dude that's
the most used story of all time oh dude
yeah it is yeah to feel bad about
something that maybe somebody would
maybe feel bad about but probably
doesn't yeah and then yeah because yeah
I know you know what's even stupider
this is the stupidest part I wouldn't be
embarrassed yeah if that happened to me
oh that's very you that's very you that
is the that is the peak stupidity of all
there's a lot of stupid [__] about it
but that is the stupidest part yeah yeah
it's true that's how I pee even now to
this day can't wait till my next 30 I
can't wait till my next therapy session
this is what I'm going to talk
about there are much bigger issues
so you claim this is really going to
change my life so hold on I I had to
relearn to do that and now I do that
what pissed with the my pants around my
ankle so you do that now as a
40something year old yeah I literally
learned when I was 38 relearned you know
uh not hard to relearn unlearned uh no
um no you those people that you're
talking about are either three and four
years old they might even be trolling
You adults just do not do that that is
not a thing adult adults do the only
thing I could argue is maybe they were
talking about from a sitting position
they do that that's the only time it's
borderline acceptable that would have
come up because this is he's getting
trying TR think of all the angles cuz
that's so even then is is wrong I still
do it the first the way yeah but if
you're overweight and you got to sit
down and do it I making up so if you're
overweight and you live in the American
South from culture on the west side of
the Mississippi River at 6 p.m. or later
like job early it's just you're tired
what children do okay and that's it
adults do it the way the guy the
submitter the submission do you ever
have you ever tried to pee with only by
just using the fly and just taking your
penis out and and your belt's still
buckled yeah yeah yeah you have I've
tried it yeah what was it like to you it
was difficult worst interview it was
difficult because it's hard to control
where all of the P go when you don't
have control over the speaking speaking
when you're not when you're not
controlling the shaft of your
coari no that's not why it's difficult
have you tried it yes okay then why did
you display shock when I said
trap difficulty is if you do it the
underwear will continue to try and rise
up and cut off the supply oh to the P
sure that's true too but you is also
take your balls out too when you pee you
take your balls out too it's yeah yeah
and you also hold your leg up with it
and everything you hold your left leg up
with your balls and dick as you pee you
take your legs out you take your legs
out no dude you it's best to control the
shaft of your winky Doodle Dandy when
you are peeing because that's where the
it's like holding a gun on the tri on
the I understand you also have to hold
your underwear down if you're just
letting it out so I'm saying take your
balls out too like you're in that
[__] amateur allure porn videos the
guy oh right yeah you do
what is that amateur Laur what the [__]
is
that Anthony knows you
know it's always funny when somebody
makes a joke about a certain kind of
porn some people don't get it somebody
else laughs hard you're like you a freak
[__] no it's it's not even
freaky it's just what they do it's
amateur lore is this we is this porn
website where this guy only takes he
never takes his pants down okay he only
if he has a belt on it's buckled oh he
unzips it takes his penis and balls out
okay and that's how he gets a [__]
and [__] hey guy take off your pants I
don't know if he likes the you know the
constriction of it or what but he I
don't know what it is I I don't know
what it is but he never you know what
actually in my head I think it might be
he's got identifiable tattoos oh and he
doesn't want people to know he does porn
cuz he never shows his face got it okay
dude
Luther Sherlock Holmes yeah sherock
Holmes CU someone would be like CU
someone will be like well why why does
he only do that a must like it must be a
king thing something doesn't make sense
does it the worst episode of Luther
there could possibly be I think you know
what it is tattoos is doesn't won't be
identified that's why it doesn't show
his face and every goes like just Ah
that's why he's Luther the reason he
only takes his [__] and balls out
instead of taging his pants all the way
down is cuz he's got identifying marks
it's up above his [__] and balls
probably like a tiger or something maybe
it's a yin and a Yang I just GNA say
yeah you did Yang yeah yeah
um maybe it's the name of a former lover
all right you know okay uh discarded
Luther episode
ideas what uh [__] what was I going to
say before oh right yeah you do have to
take to to make sure the band of the
underword does not constrict or restrict
the flow of the urine you have to lift
carefully the balls out oh no go over
over tantri sex tantric sex tantric
teacher atten Constructor dude um you
lift the balls over the band of the
underwear continue to pull the band down
so it does not restrict or constrict the
flow of the urine let the urine flow
until you are
finished shake shake shake shake your
body right doesn't know it okay and then
no and then you you gently slide the
balls and penis back yeah you don't want
to have the balls bang against the leg
okay demonetized to high
heaven but but um no I it's not it's
worth it's you think it's more it's one
of those things that you think it's more
convenient by not unbuckling your belt
it ends up being way more
work you're that's exactly right what
you said all right good I thought you
were going to disagree I was about I was
already getting a pissed off no it's
exactly right it's the most you've only
been that right you've never been more
right frankly you're never ever really
often that right in the first place no
but you can only be that right I don't
know listen this podcast is one day
going to be the biggest podcast known to
man MH share it with your friend my
special is out grow or die go to
crystalia you can get it now for 10
bucks I've worked so hard on it please
go support and check it out don't steal
it just [__] you know uh and uh
that's it go to Lifeline luxury
patreon.com Lifeline luxury leave a
comment and share this episode with your
friends man it's uh you know we want to
we want to grow like grow we want to
grow or die we want to grow or die also
check out my new upcoming podcast the
private record at the
private.com see what it's all about
submit yourself as a potential guest as
long as you got a story that's good
enough to share with the world we want
you uh privat record.com or the privat
gmail.com what else that's it
okay bye thank
you
hello
hello hello will you please hello
hello hello